the jurogan experience i feel like we
should have a drink
i i think it we would be remiss we have
to take it professionally
with a podcast to drink
that's nice we're doing a podcast about
drinking yeah that makes sense we should
have at least a small
so the historically there's been a
safety feature built into alcohol so for
most we've been drinking
thank you cheers cheers yeah
let's try this
ah whoa yeah that's nice i'll start your
monday morning i'll start your monday
there's a way to start a monday morning
yeah
um so this stuff is new so having
alcohol that's this strong
is something we've only had for a couple
hundred years really
yeah so a lot of people don't realize
that so for most of our history we've
been drinking
like two to three percent beers uh
great three percent yeah that's
historically that's typically what beers
came in at
grape wines you could get up to like
eight to ten
but there's a built-in limit to for
natural fermentation so
the yeast are turning sugars and alcohol
which is a poison
so the yeast are slowly poisoning
themselves basically
and we've bred these super hardy yeast
so like
nowadays you can get an australian syrah
to like 16
abv wow which is historically really
unprecedented but it's crazy that's as
high as you can get
because then the alcohol shuts down the
yeast
but a way around that is distillation so
you heat you take that wine
you heat it up ethanol is really
volatile so that comes off first and if
you can figure out how to capture that
vapor and turn it back into a liquid
you've got this you've got really
concentrated alcohol
do they do that with wine they do it
with wine or they take
they'll take something that's naturally
fermented so a weak beer or wine and
then they distill it
and what do they call that when they get
it on the other end distilled liquor
that's what liquor is
oh okay so it's just a kind of liquor
yeah so liquor liquor or spirits refers
to something that's been distilled so
you've
basically extracted the alcohol out of
the mixture and made it into a pure form
and once you do that you've got like 90
you can get like some vodkas could be
like 90 something percent
abv so that's crazy strong
it's just really we're not equipped to
so that what you're talking about you
know this
it needs to be modulated it was always
modulated historically
by the fact that we were drinking beers
that weren't very strong
so there's going to be just volume limit
to how much you can consume
is also modulated by social stuff so
we're drinking
typically historically in a communal
situation
where there's really clear ritual
restrictions on drinking so you only
drink when someone makes a toast
you're you're modulating your drinking
with other people
and even you know you think about just
even in a pub
you don't just drink as much as you want
you order rounds right
and if you down your your beer real fast
you got to wait until everyone else is
ready to order another round
so we socially regulate our drinking and
then it's been regulated by
its inherent weakness if you want to
think of it that way but then all of a
sudden you get this kind of stuff you
get really strong liquors
and and you can have that in your house
that's when alcohol gets really
dangerous and it's only been the last
couple hundred years yeah distilled
liquors weren't because
the concept's really simple aristotle
described
distillation but technologically it's
really hard to do
because you got to be able you have to
have metal energy you need to be able to
heat liquids and keep them at a certain
temperature
they're pressurized it's really it's
actually kind of dangerous so in
prohibition
when people created stills at home it
was like early 20th century
version of meth labs you know they were
constantly exploding and people were
like
getting scalded with hot liquid because
it's really it's dangerous so it's hard
to do so we only mastered it um
i mean i'm telling an evolutionary story
so my story begins 10 million years ago
with primate
ancestors who adapted to alcohol and
just
so 10 million years ago about
20 000 years ago to 13
000 years ago we start making alcohol
seriously not just relying on fruit
lying around that has some alcohol in it
and then
distillation happens probably around
1300s in china
and 15 1600s in europe so that sounds
like a long time ago but really
evolutionarily it's yesterday we just we
really haven't had time
culturally or genetically to adapt to
access to this kind of alcohol
and a long time ago when people were
drinking beer
and um drinking wine in particular like
a lot of
what they were doing like if they were
carrying it around with them they would
carry beer or wine
when they were going on trips because it
didn't go
bad the way water would right um beer
unhopped beer goes bad pretty quickly
it's
like a couple days a couple days yeah
there's a theory that
beer might have been useful in some
cultures because it pure
fermenting water purifies the water so
if you've got bad water from a pond or
something like that and then you ferment
it make beer out of it
yeah yeah drink it so that's one of the
story i mean the purpose of my book is
to
try to explain the puzzle of why we do
this why do we put
poisons into our body why do we like to
drink
and it's mysterious because it's so it's
really costly it's it's damaging
physiologically it's got all these
social potential social problems
and yet we've been doing it forever
we've been
making and drinking alcohol for just
about as long as we've been doing
anything
in an organized fashion in fact we the
it's looking likely that we were doing
this before agriculture
and that it's possible that the the
desire to make
beer and wine is what motivated
agriculture
so hunter-gatherers hunter-gatherers
were making
beer before they had agriculture really
yeah
and uh so they're making clay pots and
yeah there's um you know they're
pounding the stuff they're malting it to
up the sugar content i think that's the
effect of that and then they're
fermenting it
and so we have these sites like and and
what's
present day turkey the site called
goblet tepe
is this really cool ritual site it's um
these huge stone have you seen pictures
of it yeah i'm
super familiar with it because of graham
hancock who's been on my podcast
multiple times
okay obsessed with ancient civilizations
and that
is uh sort of the rosetta stone of
ancient civilizations because
it's uh at least 12 000 years old and
the thought process was
at that point in time no one could build
the kind of structures that those people
built
so when they did it it sort of uh it
lent
uh credence to some of his theories that
civilization has gone through multiple
periods of
ascension and then resets usually
through catastrophic
disasters like asteroid impacts so
his theory um it it it's not really just
his theories the younger driest impact
theory
okay and the younger dry ice impact
theory it's pointing to
the end of the ice age which coincides
with
real proof of impacts on earth
in the sense of they take soil samples
and when they go down to the same uh
amount of time
where the ice age ended they find with
this
this stuff called um it's called the
nuclear glass or
tritonite and this stuff it it
occurs at blast sites where they test
nuclear weapons
but it also occurs at asteroid impact
sites okay and they find it all over the
place
at around 12 000 south 12
000 ish years ago and so this theory
is um that at the end of the ice age
what had happened was
we passed through an area in our solar
system that is uh
rich with comets okay and then we were
hit and that um it
literally restarted civilization killed
off a massive amount of people and
stopped civilizations
dead in its tracks and then there's a
period of rebuilding so it's go blackie
tepe
telling his rebuilding no they don't
know
right it's all speculation because
gobekli tepe was for sure
covered on purpose yeah somewhere around
12 000 years ago
but that doesn't indicate how long ago
before then it was built
right but what they do know is it was
made with some pretty sophisticated
methods because
a lot of the carvings were
three-dimensional instead of carved into
the stone
the stone around it was carved away
right right to leave and there's also
like
animals in it that aren't even supposed
to be from that part of the world okay
they find that pretty fast know about
that yeah there's some pretty cool [ __ ]
to it and it's huge you know they've
only uncovered i think like 10
of it so far it's a cool sight so the
the role it plays in my story is that
you've they're hunter gatherers the
people who built this place they used to
think that but they're not necessarily
sure of that
this is the theory that graham hancock
is proposing all right
he believes that civilization so they
were like they had full-on agriculture
and they were this is just completely
theoretical
all right because and and very disputed
okay because you're dealing with
you know it's like so long ago it's hard
like what what evidence is there
this was always the evidence against
something like gobekli tepe
where's the evidence of sophisticated
structures 12 000 years ago
and then finally they found gobekli tepe
so now they're like okay
well now we have evidence of
sophisticated structures twelve thousand
years ago which should have been built
according to our timeline by
hunter-gatherers but
um they are they're they're resisting
that and they're thinking
this younger driest impact theory may
indicate
that there was something that happened
that
you know if you look at egypt there's
clearly more than one
era of building styles there's like an
old kingdom style and new can
a lot of the old stuff is like deep
under the sand when they're finding it
and it's their position that a lot of
this stuff
is thousands of years older than the
pyramids okay
so my my understanding of the site is
that it's 100
it was 100 gatherers uh there there's no
grain storage
locations they were clearly gathering
they were coming from all over and they
were gathering at this site
to build so they were working to you
know erect these pillars
and stuff and they were having blow out
feasts so they have all this
these remnants of feasting and they have
these big
vats that almost certainly contained
beer
and possibly hallucinogen-laced beer so
a lot of early so these hunter gatherers
they weren't growing
the the hops or whatever they made the
beer out of they were just finding it
wild
they're making it out of wild grains but
the argument so so the standard story
about
alcohol is we invent agriculture
then sometime after that we note that
you know someone leaves their sourdough
starter out too long and it starts to
turn into beer and they're like oh this
actually tastes alright
that's the standard story so we had
agriculture and then we get alcohol
around the 1950s or so some
archaeologists started to argue
you know sites like this one and other
sites around the world suggest that
hunter-gatherers were gathering
and making alcohol before agriculture
and so this is the beer before bread
hypothesis is that's crazy is that what
motivated people to settle down
and start focusing on making these
grains more productive
was they wanted to get high not because
they wanted to make bread
and it's it jives you see the same
pattern in other parts of the world so
in south america
they make this uh beer-like substance
chicha
out of now they make it out of maize out
of corn
but they used to make it out of the
ancient
the wild ancestor of corn is called
teosinte
and what's interesting is teosinte sucks
for making
grain like if your goal was to make
tortillas
you wouldn't even notice this plant
because the grains don't make very good
grain products to eat but it makes great
beer
is really good for making chicha so this
plant if
these early people were looking for
something to make food with they would
overlook this plant
but if they were looking for something
to make beer with they would focus on it
cultivate it start making it produce
bigger grains and that's how you would
get
corn that's like what was the did they
do we know what the original thing that
they got high with was
well we have like uh like the the
you know the first the atom
yeah i mean certainly we're getting a
little bit drunk on just naturally
fermenting fruit
so now you know fruit falls on the
ground it starts to rot
what the rotting is is some of it's
being turned into alcohol by yeast and
so clear
it's easy to discover alcohol because
it's happening naturally in our
environment all the time
the earliest evidence of deliberately
produced alcohol is from
about 13 000 years ago so a little bit
before i go back late tepe
and this is in modern day israel they
have
traces of beer production so people are
clearly
fermenting beer catch new episodes of
the joe rogan experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre
on your spotify app go to spotify now
to get this full episode of the joe
rogan experience